i was taught the basics of um uh counter
surveillance
you know some trickery and
and uh
um
surveillance detection routes where you
wander around in the city
for three hours
and
determine whether you're being followed
or not
that requires you to plan the route very
well
i give you one example that
will illustrate that
as my my favorite spot when when when i
was in moscow
i did a lot of that also
and if my favorite spot was i know it
wasn't
not well traveled uh
road it went down the hill and and
curved
and at the bottom of the hill
there was a telephone booth
and when you open the door and and pick
up the telephone
you have to look back
so it wasn't like this right it wasn't a
giveaway this was normal it was natural
so yeah yeah i could see if somebody
would come walking after me you know
these kinds of things or you would uh
you know use
public transportation uh
big buildings
uh where you
needed to use an elevator and see who's
because
surveillance
the the object of surveillance is to
never lose sight of the individual who
you're surveilling because at that point
you may miss the window where he does
something that that you're looking for
so somebody
always has to come close right did you
have to also study
surveillance no only counter
surveillance
and what helped me in in all my training
uh you know i would
be uh would have a competition with the
folks that were coming they were
following me
and me
and i beat them every time
uh they were at a disadvantage because
one of them always had to be close and
and if you saw the same face twice you
know
that you were being followed and i had a
very very good uh memory for for faces
so basically figure out a fixed route
and then a fixed route that allows you
to
uh
survey the area and then record the
faces you've seen inside your mind
and if uh you see multiple times a
single face that's that's a bad sign and
they they could they could uh you use uh
different clothes
yeah uh but they didn't have was face
masks yeah the cia does nowadays they
can give you a different face within
seconds
oh my gosh yeah
so
how bi
[Laughter]
i mean again you talk about paranoia
is that part of the is that a big part
of the job
uh counter surveillance like being
constantly paranoid that you're being
watched yeah i was supposed to isn't
that quite stressful so is that is that
one of the is that actually an effective
way to operate uh no but it sort of
becomes a routine uh i was told to do it
uh while in the us once a month
and uh okay it's like a cleaning out oh
not not every day no no no no no once a
month or
before i would say mail a letter with
secret writing so
i was sure that you know nobody saw me
put an envelope into
a
postbox so this is one of the tools in
your toolbox so there's morse code
there's yes the decryption and
encryption there's the car surveillance
you